The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So did
everyone turn in PSET1?
Yes?
Good.
OK, so there is a PSET1
critique due in a few days.
My advice?
You already did PSET1.
You remember what you
wrote out on the proof.
Look at the solution.
Write one paragraph today,
and you're done with it.
Then you go focus on PSET2.
If you leave it
off until Tuesday,
you're going to have to
read your proof again,
remember what you're thinking.
It's a lot more work.
Just do it now, get
it out of the way,
and put PSET1 behind you.
AUDIENCE: Is the critique
only for the proof?
Or is this for all of them?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
Just the proof.
So you have to compare
your proof with our proof?
AUDIENCE: Is there an
assignment for that?
Or do we just know to do it?
PROFESSOR: Uh.
PSET1 be Stellar.
Oh, no, sorry.
It's not in Stellar.
It's on our new grading
site that just went out.
So you have to go to
our new grading site,
and you have to type
in your critique there.
And it's one paragraph.
You should aim
for one paragraph.
If you're doing more
than that, then you're
doing something wrong.
And it's LATEX Plus math mode.
So you can use math mode,
and that's about it.
OK, any more questions
about the critique?
It's a new thing.
We care about it because it will
make our grading life easier.
And because it'll force you to
look at the solutions and see
what you understood
and what you didn't.
So we care about it.
Don't ignore it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Like, how
much is it weighted?
How much does it count
toward the grade?
PROFESSOR: If you
don't have a critique,
we will most likely
give you a 0 for proof.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: If your proof is bad
and your critique of the proof
is good, then you
might get something.
If your proof is bad and
you have no critique--
actually if your proof
is whatever it is and you
have no critique, you get a 0.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [CHUCKLE]
PROFESSOR: Any more
questions about that?
OK.
Who needs help remembering
what the document distance
problem is?
OK.
Everyone who went to lecture
or to [INAUDIBLE] remembers.
That's good.
Who went to lecture last time?
Cool.
That's good.
So we did insertion
sort and merge sort
from a theoretical standpoint.
Today we're going to look at
the code for the insertion sort
and, if we have time, look
at the code for merge-sort,
and use the same strategy as we
did last time to analyze them,
look at the running time, make
sure the running time matches
the theory, and see how
pseudocode turns into Python.
So you all have your listings.
Last time in document
distance, we covered Main,
and we covered most
of the functions
except for count frequency.
Can anyone remind me what
the call graph looked like?
So the call graph
is the tree that I
had up on the left,
and it started at Main.
Thank you.
So Main calls word frequencies
for file, which in turn calls?
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
probably line list.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: And count frequency.
PROFESSOR: So we pretend we
don't see the read file called.
We assume that the data
is already in memory
or that the call
takes time that's
proportional to the running--
to the length of the file.
And we only look at get-word
from line list and count
frequency.
OK.
Who else does Main call?
AUDIENCE: Vector angle?
PROFESSOR: And the vector angle?
AUDIENCE: Inner product.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's put up the constants
for-- for the document distance
problem that we used last time.
So we said that the
document has W words.
And then when you take
that list of words
and you turn it into
a distance vector,
you will get assigned
to a document vector.
You will get L elements, which
basically means L unique words.
So L is the document
vector length.
And we assume we're using a
natural language like English,
so all the words
are bounded in size.
Like 5 to 10
characters, for example.
And to make our
life easier, we say
all the words have the same
size W. So w is the word length.
Using these numbers,
can anyone remind me
what we said the costs
for these methods are?
And we didn't analyze
count frequency,
so it's OK to not
take my word for it
and not tell me what
I said last time.
But I would like numbers for
word frequencies from file,
get word from line list, vector
angle, and inner product.
AUDIENCE: Was that mu squared?
That was last time.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Which-- which one?
Does anyone-- does
anyone else want to try?
Let's not do guessing.
I'll pull them up
if nobody remembers.
I spent an entire hour on
that, and you guys did too.
It was painful.
AUDIENCE: I know.
But we had to, like, you
know, add them up, and then--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we did a lot of
work for those numbers.
So get word from line list
was order of W squared.
Does anyone remember why?
What made it take so much time?
AUDIENCE: 'Cause you
append it to the word list.
For, like, you add it to
the end to go through.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you add it.
So what?
AUDIENCE: So, like,
every time you need it,
you, like, do word list equals
word list plus words in line.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Excellent.
So get words from
line list, line five.
There's a plus there.
And that plus sign messes
up the performance.
So that's why it's w squared.
Count frequency,
we didn't cover it,
you had to take my word for it.
So we will cover it now.
And, inner product.
So suppose you have two vectors
of line-- length L1 and L2.
How much time does it take
to compute the inner product?
AUDIENCE: L1, L2 time.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how much time does
vector angle take?
AUDIENCE: L1 L2 time.
PROFESSOR: L1 L2.
So it makes three calls, right?
You get the two things.
First, it computes the inner
product of the two lists.
And then it has to compute the
inner product of each vector--
of each document
vector with itself.
Because that's what's on
the bottom of the fraction.
So what's the running
time for that?
AUDIENCE: Plus L1
squared, plus L2 squared.
PROFESSOR: Plus L1
So someone was really helpful
last time and asked me,
can you make this
simpler with some math?
And I said, I don't know
so I don't think I will.
But I looked at-- my, I
looked at my high school math
afterwards, and it turns out
that these-- so L1 squared
plus L2 squared are guaranteed
to be greater than L1 L2
as long as these
numbers are positive.
And we're working
with document list,
so they're always positive.
So this will go away.
So let's assume count frequency
is w squared or smaller.
So the total running time for
word frequencies from file
is w squared.
What's the running
time for everything?
AUDIENCE: Would just
be, like, w squared
plus L1 squared plus L2 squared?
PROFESSOR: Almost.
AUDIENCE: Actually, it depends
on which one's greater, right?
PROFESSOR: Well, almost.
So here W works, assuming you
get one document with W words.
But word frequencies from
files is called twice, once
for each document.
First document has W1 words,
second document has W2 words.
So what's the running time?
AUDIENCE: W1 squared
plus W2 squared.
PROFESSOR: W1 squared
So I take this, and I add this.
Right?
Except when I add this, if
I want to add L1 squared,
I know L1 is the number
of unique documents--
of unique words in the document.
And W1 is the total number
of words in the document.
W1 guaranteed to be
greater or equal than L1,
so it's going to dominate.
I don't need to add it.
Same for L2.
This is it.
OK.
You guys don't seem to
remember the numbers for these.
So that means I didn't
torture you enough last time.
So let's do more.
Let's look at count frequency.
And let's compute
the cost for that.
So what we did last time was, we
went through each line of code.
We thought, how
much time does it
take to execute the line once?
And how many times
does the line run?
And then we compute the product
of that, add everything up,
and that's the cost
for the function.
First off, before
I put numbers here,
what does the method to do?
AUDIENCE: It takes
a list of words--
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: For each
item in that list,
checks to see if
it's-- you know,
list of words that
it's-- counted, right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're telling me
what the code does.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Try to
look at Main or try
to look at word
frequencies for files.
So look at it top-down, and tell
me what the purpose of it is.
What's the goal?
AUDIENCE: Making a list
of-- and each object
is a list with a
word and a number.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Excellent.
So big picture, I have
the first document.
I read it in.
I break it up into words.
And I have a list of words.
That's what word
frequencies for file
gives me-- sorry, that's what
you get words from line list
gives me.
List of words.
The fox is in the hat.
And this gets passed
to count frequency,
and count frequency
gives me, you said,
an object, which is a list.
Of lists, where each
of them has the word
and how many times it shows up.
So I would have "the" shows
up twice, "fox" shows up
once, "is" shows up
once, "in" shows up once,
and-- I need a shorter
example-- "hat" shows up once.
So it takes this and
turns it into that.
So on line 2, I have a
list L that's initialized.
And then, at the
end, it's returned.
So I'm going to guess that L
is going to look like this.
Line 3, for new word in word
list, iterates over the input.
So iterates over this.
And then, line 4 checks
to see, for each new word,
it looks at the list that
I have under construction.
So exam-- for example, if
I ran through all the words
and then I'm trying to
put in hat right now,
I wouldn't have it here.
What line 4 does is, it
looks at all the entries.
And it says, if I
can find the words--
so if I can find the
word hat somewhere here--
then increment the number.
If I can't, then
make a new entry
and say that the word shows up
once, because it's the first
I see it.
So this is what the code does.
Now let's see how
fast it does that.
So line 2 initialize the
output to an empty list.
What's the cost for that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very good.
How many times?
For new word in word lists.
Cost?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I know the cost is 1.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we are-- here,
it's a bit confusing, right?
We're saying that, oh, there's
does iteration over a list.
And each step of the
iteration is constant time,
but the iteration
happens L times.
I'm sorry, not L times.
The length of the list times.
How many-- how many
elements are in word lists?
I heard a very low W, so
I will pretend I heard it.
Or I hope I heard W. So
word list, the words I
got from the document,
W. How about the if.
So, it looks at the
word that I have-- oh.
This code is confusing because
I forgot a line, right?
Pretend that between line--
oh, no, sorry, I didn't.
New word is-- new word
is assigned in line 3.
So new word in line 3 is
compared to the first element
of the entry that's
assigned in line 4.
So hat is compared with
the, fox, so on, so forth.
And if the comparison is
true, it runs line 6 and 7.
And if not, it keeps looping.
So line 5, the if how,
many times does it run?
Just the comparison.
AUDIENCE: W.
PROFESSOR: W.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no, no, no.
No.
I'm thinking of line 4.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Yeah.
I'm getting confused too.
So let's start with line 4.
Sorry.
Shouldn't do line 5.
AUDIENCE: --new word,
then you're not-- like,
you're not going to
run through that again.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Let's worry about
that right afterwards.
Let's do line 4 first.
Sorry, I jumped over line 4.
So, line 4 definitely
runs W times
because it's inside the for
loop from line 3 to line 9.
So everything here will
definitely run W times.
But how many times
does it run overall?
So, line 4 iterates over
all the entries here.
How many times does that happen?
AUDIENCE: 1 plus W
over-- times 10/2,
because it's just worst case,
L-- the length of L increases
by 1 every time.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so I like that
you started with worst case.
Normally I would
say exactly that.
Worst case or W. But we
had a different constant
for the number of words
that you have in the end.
So let's say something a little
bit better than W. Let's say,
let's put the lower bound on it.
So yeah, worst case, all
the words are different.
But what if they're
not all different?
And what if in the end
I know I have L words?
CLASS: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Worst case.
Almost.
So, I know I have a W
from the outer loop.
For each word in the
outer loop, how many times
does the inner loop execute?
How many times do I have
to go through something
in the inner list?
So I know here I have
W words, suppose here I
have L elements in the vector.
For each one of
these, how many times
do I have to go through--
So how many elements do I
have to go through here?
AUDIENCE: Depends on
where you are, though.
For the first word, you
only have to go through one.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
But--
AUDIENCE: For the second
word, you have to through--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
But I heard the worst case.
And I like that,
because it's easier
to reason about the worst case.
And most of the time it's
sort of like the average case.
AUDIENCE: So then,
length of list-- L.
PROFESSOR: The length of the
list, and that's L. Worst case,
the first words that I see
will be L different words.
And then all the
words that I see
will be the same as the
words that I saw before.
So worst case, the list
will grow to L very fast,
and then I'll keep
seeing L L L. And I'll
ignore what was there
in the beginning,
and I'll say L times.
So I know the second list
is bounded by L in length,
the first list is
bounded by W in length.
So worst case this
runs L times W times.
And what's the
cost of iterating?
AUDIENCE: What is the
difference between L and W?
L is the document vector length,
and W is the number of words.
But isn't the number of
elements in the document vector
the number of words?
PROFESSOR: How about this case?
What's W?
AUDIENCE: 6, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So L is the number
of unique words in a document.
And I heard a
really cool argument
that I liked last time.
Does anyone remember?
About L?
If we're really dealing with a
natural language like English,
how many words do
I have in English?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think, at the max,
there's actually around
250,000, but a lot of them
are not used anymore.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So 250,000, right?
Max.
So that's a constant.
If I have a document
that contains
all the writings of all the
authors that were ever done,
and say that's a billion words,
L is still going to be 250,000.
Right?
So L can be very
different from W.
That's why we're keeping
track of them separately.
One W L times W. What's
the cost of iterating?
So we know how many
times line 4 runs,
but what's the cost of one
step of iterating in the list?
1.
Very good.
Line 5.
How many times does it run?
AUDIENCE: W times L?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Same as line 4, right?
The if is run all the time.
And lines 5 and 6 only run
sometimes, but-- sorry,
line 6 and 7 only run sometimes,
but line 5 runs all the time.
What is the cost?
AUDIENCE: We can
say it's constant.
PROFESSOR: We can
I like we can say
it's constant, but why
is it that we can
say it's constant?
Why don't I just say 1,
if-- this is an empty list.
This is a number.
AUDIENCE: Depends
on the word length.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It depends on the word
lis-- length, very good.
AUDIENCE: And we're
assuming that words
are all the same length.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: And?
So, 1 times L W. Little w.
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
So we do assume that all the
words are the same length.
But unless I tell you that
the length is really small,
which I did, you can't say 1.
So, when you said we can say
it's constant, it's right.
We can say, but we
also have to say why,
or at least think
why, that's the case.
So it's W-- we're going to use
W here and when we copy it here,
we're going to forget about it.
AUDIENCE: Can you put
a top bar on the W,
just so I can tell that
it's not the other W.
PROFESSOR: OK But you have to
be responsible for reminding
me to put that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So string comparison,
not constant.
If I have two very
long strings that
only differ in the
last character,
I have to go through them
character by character
by character until I find
the last character that's
different.
Because until I look at that,
the strings might be equal.
So comparing two
long strings takes
time that's proportional to
the length of the strings.
OK, so line 5 costs
w, tricky part,
runs L times W part--
L times W times.
How about line 6 and 7?
I didn't ask line 6, I
asked line 6 and 7 together,
because there is a trick there.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
constant for line 6, right?
PROFESSOR: Why?
AUDIENCE: 'Cause it's a number.
And one place in the entry.
We've already grabbed the entry.
PROFESSOR: So the cost
of running it once is 1.
Good.
I can tell you that that's
the same case for 7.
How many times do they run?
This is the hard part.
AUDIENCE: Wait, does break
line break out of one loop?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Break breaks out of the
loop between lines 4 and 7.
I have a question.
AUDIENCE: Is L supposed
to be not in line with if?
Yes.
PROFESSOR: It is supposed
to be where it is.
I will talk-- yes.
So what happens is, that
else is in line with a for.
And if the for loop
runs to completion,
then it does get executed.
If there's a break
somewhere inside the for,
then it doesn't get executed.
So the idea behind
that is, usually
use this for finding stuff.
So you iterate over a list,
and when you find something,
break out of the loop.
You did something, you
If you didn't find it,
you can put an else
and then say what code happens.
And you don't have to
write code on your own
to check if you broke
out of the loop.
So if break executes,
then it's going
to take us out of the loop.
It's going to ignore the else.
And it's going to run
the loop on line 3 again.
So it's going to do
another iteration.
So line 6 and 7, how many times?
AUDIENCE: W minus L?
PROFESSOR: W minus L.
AUDIENCE: Like, if
it's the difference
in number of words and
number of-- unique words.
PROFESSOR: Smart.
You gave the precise answer
right the first time.
W minus L. Very good.
And what happens once--
what happens once this runs?
Why do I know-- why do I know
that the if won't be-- Oh.
Sorry, I'm getting
myself confused.
So it's going to run W
minus L times total, right?
Total times overall
without this W thing here,
so I should put
an arrow and say--
Now suppose I
didn't notice this.
Is there another way I
can get the decent bounds?
So this is the right,
perfect answer.
You have this, you're done.
You don't need to think further.
Suppose you don't have this.
What else can you do?
AUDIENCE: But we
don't have what?
PROFESSOR: If I didn't
notice that, hey, there
are L words-- There
are L new words,
W words total, so W minus
L words repeat themselves.
So this is how many times
the if is going to be true.
If I didn't have
that, then I could
see that line 7 breaks
out of the loop.
So if that if runs
once, then we're done.
We're out of the loop.
It's not going to run again.
So a bound that's not as
precise as the one you gave me
is 1 times W, because it
runs, at most, once per loop.
Does people see this?
So this is an easy way
to cop out of thinking.
And I don't like to think more
than necessary, because you
have finite time on
a test or in life,
and you don't want to spend
too much time on one thing.
We covered the loop.
Let's look at else and append.
I already got a
helpful question,
so I explained when
the else would run.
The running time for else.
Else is a flow--
control flow statement.
It's like break,
so Python will keep
track of whether a
loop completed or not
in constant time.
I'll give you that.
That's in the cost model.
How many times does
this else run, at most?
OK, L. Good.
Perfect.
How about line 9?
Loop stops here.
How many times does it run?
That's easy.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
And what does it do?
It's an append.
What's the cost for append?
AUDIENCE: Constant.
PROFESSOR: OK Line 10
runs how many times?
What's the cost?
AUDIENCE: 1?
PROFESSOR: You guys didn't
listen to me last time.
So I was saying you have
to look at the notes
and you have to practice this.
Because you have to have
this model in your mind.
So that when you're
writing code,
this has to happen
automatically.
You shouldn't have to
think explicitly about it.
Because if you do, you're
not going to do it.
AUDIENCE: For the
else, shouldn't it
be W tim-- I mean, it would
be called W times not L times?
Because you want to look
at the outer loop and not
the inner loop?
So it can-- you call all--
once at the end of the total--
the inner for.
Right?
So, so it could be-- happen W
times, maximum, not L times.
'Cause the L is the for loop
that the else coincides with.
And the else would
only happen once
for every total
iteration of that.
PROFESSOR: OK so
you're proposing W
as the bound for
the else, right?
Here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So I could say,
hey, it runs, at most,
once for outer loop.
So it's, at most, W times.
This is a nice, easy argument.
We have a bound.
L is a tighter bound.
And when I got L,
what happened here
was the same kind of
thinking that you did earlier
to get this.
So this bound is good,
this bound is tighter.
This bound is good,
And the argument behind
this one is that, hey, this
else only happens for new words.
If there's no new-- if the
word that I looked at is old,
then break is going to execute.
And else is not
going to execute.
So that's why I can say L.
The beauty of
asymptotics is that I
can use either of the
bounds and I'll still
get the correct running time.
So I'm not going to
fuss over it too much.
I like the tighter ones, because
it means you guys are thinking.
And you're looking
at the algorithm,
and you're understanding it.
But if you don't
have them, you'll
still get the correct
running times.
So I think that's nice.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's get the
running time for everything.
Can someone do it in one step?
Then let's do it step by step.
So let's compute
partial products.
What are they?
AUDIENCE: 1.
W. LW.
L, W, little w-- with the bar.
AUDIENCE: (LAUGHING)
With the bar.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: W minus L. W. L, L, 1.
PROFESSOR: OK, so if I add them
up, this is all asymptotic.
So the biggest
one will dominate.
In general, I can
just take a max
instead of doing
actual addition.
So who dominates here?
AUDIENCE: The fourth one down?
PROFESSOR: Fourth-- OK.
Yep.
So line 5 is the biggest time
consumer in this algorithm.
And I know it's W times w-bar.
So now I'm going
to copy it here.
What did I say I'll do
when I'm copying it here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So I'm assuming English
five- to ten-character words.
W L. And W L is
smaller than w squared,
so the assumption that
I had before is correct.
I don't have to
change anything here.
That is good.
So we noticed last time,
and already forgot by now,
that the biggest problem in
this whole implementation
was the plus in get
words from line list.
Suppose we forgot about it and
we have this big pile of code,
how do I go about
making it faster?
Method one, go
through every method.
Do this.
Compute the running times, and
see which one's the slowest.
Does this scale to
1,000 lines of code?
Not so much.
We're going to be giving you
roughly 1,000 lines of code
for PSET2, and we're going
to ask it to make it faster.
Do want to understand
everything?
No.
Instead what you want
to do is run the code
through a profiler.
So we have a computer.
The computer can
tell you which line
takes the most time to run.
So you don't have to
do it on pen and paper.
Whenever we can automate, do so.
So we'll teach you
how to run a profiler.
It's in the notes.
And if you look in
the code outputs right
after [INAUDIBLE], you'll
see a profiler output.
So what that tells you
is for each function,
how much time does it take--
that's the total time?
And there's the
cumulative time, which
is how much does it take
together with its children?
In this case for word
frequencies from file, order
of W-- this is how
much time it takes
including the
functions it's called.
So this is the cumulative time.
Cumulative time is useful if
I'm during runtime analysis.
Is not so useful if
I'm looking at where's
the slowness in my program?
Because if you look
at cumulative time,
you might see the slowness
in one of the functions that
get-- that word frequencies
from file called.
So the cumulative time
for this is really big,
but the total time-- the
time that's spent inside it--
is not that bad.
Instead if you
look at total time,
you'll see that the worst
function is-- surprise,
surprise-- get words
from line list.
So 5 lines to look at--
hey, there's a plus there.
I remember from lecture
that plus copies over lists,
and it's kind of slow, so maybe
I should use something else.
Does d remember what
else we should use?
We talked about that
last recitation.
Extend.
Document distance 2 .
The only difference between
it an document distance 1
is get words from
line list, line 5.
That plus turned into an extend.
One character turned to six,
so about eight keystrokes,
30% runtime improvement.
Very good return on investment.
Everything else is
going to be harder.
So let's look at that line,
because that line dominated
the running time of get
words from line list.
And think what's, then,
your running time for it
now that I have extend?
Does anyone remember what get
words from line list does?
AUDIENCE: It gets the
words out of the document.
PROFESSOR: OK .
It gets the word
out of the document.
So it reads a document that
looks like a regular text file,
and it gets this out of it.
The way it does that is
it goes through each line,
reads the line as a string,
breaks up the string
into a list of words,
and then combines
all those lists
of words together.
Get words from string,
line 4, returns
the number of words in a line.
Sorry, the list of words
in the line, and then
extend combines
the lists together.
Let's add some constants
that we had last time.
I think we had that K is the
number of words per line.
And Z is the number
of total lines.
So this K is actually-- W
over Z. No, I don't like that.
That's work.
So Z is K W over
K. And we argued
that we're not going
to talk about K
too much, because a document
needs to fit on a screen
or needs to fit on
a piece of paper.
So the line length has
to be finite, right?
Otherwise, if I have a document
that has 10,000 character
lines, I can't even
write it on this board.
Even though it's really long.
So K, the number of words in
a line, is going to be finite.
But we'll need it
for this analysis.
So line 4 returns a list
with the words on a line.
How many elements in that list?
This returns a list
with how many elements?
AUDIENCE: Could K
[INAUDIBLE] words on line.
PROFESSOR: So even if
I ask easy questions,
you guys have to answer.
Because otherwise I'll
stall until you do.
So 4 gives me a list
with K elements,
and 5 appends that small
list to the big list of words
in the entire document.
Before I used plus and
that did something bad.
Now I'm using extend.
What's the cost of
one extend called?
AUDIENCE: Constant?
Order of K?
PROFESSOR: I want to know
your Python implementation.
AUDIENCE: If Python did
it like a linked list ,
like doubly linked lists,
could be order constant?
PROFESSOR: I like your question.
So if Python lists were
actually linked lists--
so if the name
wasn't confusing--
then yes, merging two
lists would be constant.
But then accessing one element
in the middle of a list
would not be constant anymore.
Say I want to access
element number
200 in a list of
10,000 elements.
I have to go through
200 elements.
We didn't do linked
lists when we
ran it, so don't worry about it.
So they decided that it's
less confusing to have
lists actually be arrays.
So Python lists, array in CLRS.
AUDIENCE: That can use
their storage contiguously?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So when you copy,
why can't you copy a block?
Why do you have to
access each other?
Does that make sense?
PROFESSOR: So, you
can copy a block,
but in order to copy
a block, you still
have to move everything.
So if your block
is 10,000 elements,
you still have to move 10,000
bytes times element size.
And the CPU works on 4 bytes
at a time or 8 bytes at a time.
OK.
But this is the
right kind of thing
to be thinking about when
you're doing the cost model.
And this is what you
want to have in your head
when you're writing Python.
So, good.
I like your question.
I wanted to say
that at some point,
but I didn't get
the occasion yet.
Lists in Python are
not lists in CLRS.
OK.
So with that long
explanation, an extend
is a list-- is a sequence
of appends, right?
If you have two
lists and you want
to extend the first
list to the second list,
extend basically goes through
each element in the second list
and calls append
on the first list.
The list is length K, the
second list is length K,
so K appends are
going to happen.
And append is constant time.
Total cost, K.
Now many times does line 5 run?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very good.
So what is the
total running cost
of the algorithm if this
is the line that dominates?
I don't want to do
every other line,
so I'll promise that this
is the line that dominates.
What is the total running time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Very good.
K times L. And that is?
Oh, K. So I shouldn't have
said K times L, sorry.
L is not the number of lines.
L is the number here, so
Z is the number of lines.
So it's K times Z. Which
means I'm using bad letters,
so please bear with me.
We'll forget about
them in a minute.
So K times Z equals?
AUDIENCE: W.
PROFESSOR: W. So
what do I write here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Good.
Very good.
What do I write here?
Word frequencies from file.
AUDIENCE: W L.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What do I write here?
AUDIENCE: W 1.
AUDIENCE: We have to-- put L
1 squared and L 2 squared back
in.
PROFESSOR: OK, do we?
Well, the-- No.
W, you want to always be
bigger than L. I hope.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So if I put it
in, L 1 squared is
L 1 L 1, which is
smaller than W 1 L 1.
But I have to think about
it before doing that.
I can't ignore this completely.
So this is document distance 2.
The asymptotic complexity
improved, the running time
improved.
Next thing that happens
to make this faster
is-- I'm not giving you
the profiler output,
but you have to take my word for
it that the longest methods are
count frequency
and inner product.
So what I'm going
to do first is I'm
going to make inner
product faster.
But in order to do
that, I have to make
word frequencies
for file slower.
And that is because
I happen to know
an algorithm for inner product
that is a lot faster, if only
you can promise me that in this
list, the words are ordered.
The words are sorted.
So what happens in that list
1 is, the moment I see a word,
if it's not in the list
I add it at the end.
So the words here show up
pretty much in the order
that they show up in the file.
Well, if instead I
could have something
that looks like-- what is it?
Fox.
In.
His.
Hat is somewhere here.
So if these words
would be in this order,
together with the
word that I'm missing,
then I can combine two lists.
I can do an inner
product a lot faster.
Let's see how that would work.
And I'm already getting confused
my words, so let's do a trick.
Let's say that instead of
words, we'll use numbers.
So instead of saying
"the," I'm going
to say the is the 50th
word in the dictionary.
So I'm going to use number 50.
Because I want to write numbers.
The numbers are
easier to deal with.
So say the first
document that I have--
the fox is in the hat-- as
words number 3, 4, 6, 8, and 9.
And they show up twice,
once, once, once.
9, once.
And say I'm trying to compute
the inner product of this
with a document that
has word number 2
showing up once, word number
3 showing up once, word number
6 showing up once, word
number 7 showing up once,
word number 8 showing up once.
OK, the algorithm for inner
product that we talked
about last time was, go
through each element in one
of the vectors, find an
element with the same word
in the second vector,
and if you can find it,
then take the number of
times the words show up
and multiply them.
So here I have a 3, 2.
I would find this element
here that has 3, 1.
I have these everywhere.
And I take the 2 and the
1 and I multiply them.
So the 3s have to be the same,
then I think the 2 and the 1,
and I multiply them.
And for all the elements
where that's case,
I add up the results
of the multiplication.
So step one, go through
each element in a vector.
That's not going to get
faster if this other vector is
sorted, right?
But the step of looking up the
second element can be sped up.
The first and easiest way I
can speed this up is, hey,
this is sorted.
If I'm looking up three,
why not do a binary search?
What would be the
cost if I do that?
So here I have L1 element,
here I have L2 elements.
What's the cost of doing
one binary search here?
AUDIENCE: Log of L2?
PROFESSOR: OK.
And how many times do
I do a binary search?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if I go
through each element here
and I do a binary search, which
is a nice and easy algorithm
that I can explain
in 10 seconds,
I'm already faster than L1 L2.
So it's worth sorting.
Now, the algorithm
that we use in class
takes time proportional
to L1 plus L2.
So that's even
trickier, and it's
going to take a bit
more time to explain.
Does-- did anyone understand
the algorithm for class
and wants to help me explain it?
Didn't think so.
OK.
So idea is that both of
these vectors are sorted.
So if I have a 3 here and I
found my 3 here, next time when
I get to 4, I know
for sure that 4 is not
going to be anywhere here,
because this vector is sorted.
Say I couldn't find
4, then I go to 6.
If 6 is here, when I
have to look for 8,
I know for sure that 8 is not
going to be anywhere up here.
So what I do is, I have a
pointer here that remembers,
where's the last element
that I have seen?
Does this make sense to people?
So when I start here
and I look at 3,
I have a pointer here that says,
I didn't see anything here.
I look at 2, it's not 3.
It's smaller.
I look at 3.
I found it, good.
I do my product.
Then I go look for the
next element here, 4.
I look at 6.
6 is bigger than 4.
So I know for sure that nothing
below it is going to be 4.
So I can stop right here
and keep my pointer here.
Then I go to 6 here.
And I look here.
Where did I stop?
I stop here.
This element matches this.
I do my product.
Keep it in.
Now I go to 8 here.
I was at 6.
6 is smaller than 8.
7 is smaller than 8.
8 is equal to 8.
I found something.
Sweet.
I do a product.
And then I stop.
And I look at the next element.
I know for sure that nothing
here is going to be 9,
so I can keep looking down.
I hit the end of my list.
OK.
Whatever I have down here--
it's going 9, 10, 11, 12--
is not going to be in this
list, because it was sorted.
So I can stop.
AUDIENCE: How do
you keep going--
What algorithm so you use
to keep looking down on L2?
PROFESSOR: Plus 1.
AUDIENCE: So what if--
PROFESSOR: I keep going down.
AUDIENCE: What if the left
side was 3, 4, 6, 9243?
PROFESSOR: 9,000, what?
AUDIENCE: Just a big number.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Then you have to
increment by 1 each time--
PROFESSOR: So I'm
not incrementing
the number I'm looking at.
Here, I looked at 6.
Then I'm looking for 8.
And after I found 8,
I'm looking for 19,000.
So I'm going to go down,
either until I find 90,000
or until I stop.
AUDIENCE: So are you going
to go down one at a time,
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --why not
do a binary search?
PROFESSOR: Because if
I do a binary search,
the analysis that says it's
fast is not going to work.
It turns out that this gives
me the optimal running time.
If I do a binary search, suppose
I have a list that's like this.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, all the
way down to 10,000.
Ugh, I can't write.
And I have another list
that's like this- 1, 2, 3, 4,
all the way down to 10,000.
1, 1.
I do a binary search,
takes log N. I look at 2.
I do a binary search, takes
almost log N. I look at 3,
do a binary search, takes
almost log N. So on, so forth.
So this is--
AUDIENCE: But if your
left list had been
PROFESSOR: Log N plus log N.
AUDIENCE: --10,000.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You'd
have taken N time.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well, this algorithm
takes N time,
even if I have to
list like this.
It takes 10,000
plus 10,000 time.
Whereas this algorithm will
take time that's actually
proportional to
10,000 log 10,000.
You believe me.
So, a way to look at this
is to do bounds and say,
for the elements
1 through 5,000,
it's going to do a binary search
for more than 5,000 elements.
So, the time-- the running
time is definitely bigger
than N over 2 log N over 2.
Constant.
This becomes log N
minus 1 and log N.
That is a good question.
I wondered about that the first
time I saw merge-sort too.
And I was thinking,
hey, I'm going
to do a binary search
here because it's faster,
and I'm going to make a faster
algorithm than anyone has ever
seen.
Well, if you do the
analysis, not so much.
But you need to think
about it, and you
need to know why that's
true or that's not true.
So I like your question.
Thank you.
So now let's get down so
the plain old merge-sort
that everyone-- sorry,
merge that everyone knows.
So if we go through
these one by one,
how many times am I going to
be advancing this pointer?
In total?
AUDIENCE: L2?
PROFESSOR: L2 times.
So this pointer can
only go down, right?
So worst case is going
to go down L2 times.
And then I'm done
with the list, return.
How many elements am I
going to look through?
So how many times does this
pointer going to advance?
AUDIENCE: L1?
PROFESSOR: This one.
AUDIENCE: But I thought, like--
AUDIENCE: Then you get
extra ones in between.
PROFESSOR: What if
L2 is bigger than L1?
What if--
AUDIENCE: Oh, right.
OK, never mind.
The reason I said
L2 was because--
PROFESSOR: You're thinking after
I'm going through this list,
I'm out, right?
AUDIENCE: Right,
that's what I thought.
PROFESSOR: So, your answer
works if this list, say, has
10 elements and this has 10,000.
And I go through this
one really quickly.
But if this list has 10 elements
and this list has 10,000,
and they both start
with 1 through 10,
I have to say a 1 because
that's a better bound.
So I have to say this.
AUDIENCE: Could you
say the opposite value
of the difference
between the two of them?
Because if you're going
to stop at 1 has 10
and the other one has
10,000, and let's say
that only the first
ten are actually equal,
then you're going to go
through that list, find all 10,
and you stop.
That would be 9,000--
PROFESSOR: I could say about
that if I'm looking at one
case, but the magic trick
is-- let's-- we're looking
at the worst case.
So worst case, if
I have 10 elements,
they'll be all the way
down in the other list.
Or they won't be there at all.
And I have to go down
through all the list.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So worst
case, L1 plus L2.
Let me see if I
have any time left.
Nope.
So, what I would like you to do
is go through insertion sort.
Insertion sort
matches the textbook.
Look at the definition in the
textbook, look at the code,
convince yourself it's the same.
Look at the running
time, convince yourself
it's N squared.
Then look at inner product
and convince yourself
that this is what it does.
Go through this line by
line, see where they match,
put the cost on.
Make sure that the
cost is L1 plus L2.
And last, go through
merge-sort and notice
that merge in [INAUDIBLE]
6 is exactly the same
as inner product.
So this pointer
magic that I did here
is exactly what's
happening inside merge.
And understand merge-sort.
Look at the textbook,
look at the notes,
and see how they match.
OK.
Thanks, guys.